6 25 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about some wicked smart ko
knutson middle school students they're
in the top 10 for a chance at a hundred
thousand dollars from samsung to make
what might sound like a crazy idea into
reality
sixth and seventh graders in steve
gaskill's science class found a problem
bus stops get so hot that people won't
often sit on the benches because they
are afraid that they will get burned the
solution they came up with wasn't just
right around the corner it's in the
school's backyard the bus stop buyer
school has steel benches which feel very
hot in the summer
so we researched alternative materials
we could use to replace the steel
one material that stood out to us was
lightweight concrete made from sunflower
stalks
we already grow sunflowers in our school
garden and normally the old stocks just
go in the trash
after learning about sunflower stock
concrete we decided to recycle last
year's stocks
we shredded the stocks and used them to
replace gravel in a standard concrete
mix but the kids didn't stop there
taking their story to the regional
transportation commission
man sunflower stock concrete all right
shout out to 8th grader ivey fewer born
for making that video and to the well
spoken sixth grader callie pippin so
getting to the final ten with the other
schools from around the country has
already won the local kids 50 grand but
you can help them win it all by voting
for them we got the link in the online
version of this story at 8newsnow.com if
you know something that's cool at school
let us know cool it's cool under the
community tab at 8newsnow.com or just
email cool at school at eightnewsnow.com